several flash mobs are planned in Berlin
to protest against the city's ban on
rallies marking at nakbar day
Palestinians say it's the second
consecutive year they've been denied the
right to protest Al Jazeera stepped
Fasteners with us now live in Berlin so
a step from yesterday the rally was
banned well people though are determined
to protest today that's right yes
well absolutely they are very determined
to still protest and get it here in
Berlin but the situation has become a
bit tense now in the last few minutes
police has arrived are now questioning
the Palestinian people who were aiming
here to commemorate the 75th nakbar day
and now they are sort of surrounding
this uh this crowd it was only a very
small group of people who showed up here
to have basically this flash mob it was
sort of a dance that they were planning
to do so they said it's not a real
protest so they can't ban it but police
in Berlin has banned all nakba protests
not only this year but also last year as
well and I am here with one of the
people who I wanted to participate so
what is happening what is police asking
you they are asking why we are here and
it's actually a spontaneous action it's
bombing are falling on Gaza people are
being killed while they are sleeping
whole families are known more part of
the Civil register I am from Gaza and I
want to have the possibility to mourn
the families and to mourn the people who
are dying in in like within this
European silence but police here says
it's not allowed together to protest to
commemorate this day they said it's
spontaneous you should have registered
that yesterday but this will be
discussed further with them so we will
see the possibility wasn't there to
register to register the demonstration
before and it's like a right guaranteed
by the constitutional
um by the Constitution so we are taking
this right as a part of the society we
have the right to be also in public
spaces to mourn our fallen people as
well but it is a band there was a ban on
yesterday's nakbar demonstration uh so
also today last year as well it's
becoming increasingly difficult for
Palestinians to protest in Germany yeah
it's actually I would say it's now um
it's building the top of the
anti-palestinian racism in Germany and
the racism of the institutions in
Germany and
um the reasons for this are various and
I'm not really I don't know
what's like what's the most important
one but the police told me when I talked
to them this morning they said there is
a tendency of anti-Semitism what do you
think about that I think this is just
I don't know if you have to cut
this from the report anyway I think this
is just stupid and not real of course
there is anti-Semitic or racist
um
chance from just individuals and those
injured individuals cannot be
generalized for a whole minority in
Germany which is being put onto a
general suspect and being
um like taken away of its own rights to
a public attendance and demonstration
you think that they are making a too
much of a comparison between
anti-Semitism and anti-israel
protest space I wouldn't even call it
anti-israel process I would protest I
will call it Palestinian protests and
this is actually a very important
Framing and it's very anti-Semitism is
being weaponized in this country since
years but now we are on the top of this
weaponizing like 96
96 of all anti-semitic attacks in
Germany are made by the right Wingers in
Germany who are in the German bundestag
and we Palestinians are still have to
justify why we are going on the street
in support of our people back home there
do you understand the sensitivities here
after the Holocaust of course happened
in Germany um I think my shirt says
everything about it the sensitivity
um would actually dictate that the
German and the German State takes a real
responsibility toward real anti-Semitism
and not just project all the forms of
racism happening in in Germany on the
Palestinian minority this is just they
are trying to wash their hands pure with
the Palestinian blood and this is not
acceptable thank you very much for
joining us we're still waiting what's
going to happen here police are still
deliberating what the consequence of
these talks are about this protest
that's about to happen we will see
what's going to happen after they are
finished talking step many thanks indeed
I'll just zero step faster in Berlin and
I'm sorry about the the bad language
it's live television and uh what a guest
says on live TV is beyond our control